قناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن
وابل كثيف من الصواريخ على منطقه عسقلان
في الوقت الذي تحدثت فيه وائل عن اطلاق
رشقات صاروخيه جديده من مواقع مختلفه في
اتجاهات مختلفه الياسكا من جنوب عسقلان ما
الذي يصلك من كل هذا من مشاهد او معلومات
مستويات مختلفه ايضا من جانب القبه
الحديديه المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تمكنت في جولات المواجهه الاخيره من قراءه
كيفيه عمل القبه الحديديه وهي تحاول ارباك
القبه الحديديه عن طريق عده وسائل تتبعها
المقاومه وهي رشقات صاروخيه كثيفه
ومتتاليه بحيث ان منظومه من يعملون على
القبه الحديديه لا يستطيعون تلقيمها
بالصواريخ اللازمه للاعتراضات وبالتالي
الجيش الاسرائيلي يحتاج الى منصات اعتراض
اكثر واكثر في تلك المناطق وبالتالي كثافه
الصواريخ كثافه النيران واطلاق الصواريخ
على ارتفاعات متعدده بمعنى قصيره ومتوسطه
وبعيده المدى كل هذا يربك منظومه القبه
الحديديه نحن شاهدنا هنا في منطقه نتيفا
عصره ومنطقه زكيم ان الاعتراضات كانت على
مستوى منخفض جدا يعني يكاد يكون قريبا جدا
من س الارض بمعنى ان القبه الحديديه في
حاله ارتباك وحتى ان صواريخ تمير
المستخدمه في عمليه الاعتراض هذه تراها
وكانها تلاحق صواريخ
المقاومه وهي مرتبكه ومتردده ولا تعرف الى
اي تريد ان تصيد هذه الصواريخ الان ايضا
فوق زكيم فوقنا تماما اعتراض صاروخ اخر
يبدو انه كان صاروخا بعيد المدى شاهدنا
بالفعل عده رشقات صاروخيه متتاليه
عنيفه للغايه وفي اتجاهات متعدده صبت في
القطاع الشمالي
والشرقي لغلاف غزه لكن بالتزامن مع ذلك
كانت هنالك صواريخ استطعنا ان نضع ونستطيع
ان نحدد الصواريخ بعيده المدى لانها تنطلق
الى طبقات الجو العليا وهي تكون موجهه
بالعاده صوب
عسقلان وايضا المناطق الجنوبيه
لتل ابيب وهنالك صافرات الانذار التي دوت
في يافني يعني بمعنى نحن نتحدث عن الضواحي
الجنوبيه
لمدينه تل ابيب التي اصبحت في مرمى هذه
الاستهدافات للمقاومه بالفعل كانت عمليه
اطلاقات متتاليه وسريعه وكما اشرت حاولت
المقاومه كما فعلت في جولاتي
قتالا سابقا
عن
ارداك القبه الحديديه في كثير من الاطلاق